17 days of coronavirus quarantine escape
at last carrying only hand luggage the
British passengers stranded on the
Diamond Princess cruise ship in Japan
are finally heading home they have the
flight home this should have been the
last time we slept in this big
comfortable bed hopefully this is my
last breakfast in Japan hello are you
apart for more than two weeks Alan and
Vanessa Sanford haven't left their room
an evacuation flight will bring them
home on Saturday but not to freedom to
14 days more quarantine I think I might
struggle a bit more with this second lot
of 14 days what's worrying you well just
that you can't get on with your life
everything's on hold and you also feel
but I've got this certificate that says
I'm negative for the virus and nobody on
the aircraft is going to be anything
other than negative for the virus it
just seems excessive but I do understand
as well that people are nervous about
having people back in the country as the
British get ready to leave the once
bustling ship is now almost empty shaaka
Mary Celeste totally empty cabin fever
has set in I really love a crossroad
across ten letters begins with a Q
quarantine this facility on the where'll
is where they'll spend the next
fortnight evacuees from Wuhan also
stayed here once sent this message to
the passengers don't be worried you're
going to a fantastic place I won't lie
you know it is going to be boring at
times but you know if you can sort of
interact with others a little bit
and you know use the entertainment
systems that you have the time should
pass pretty quickly more than 600 people
on this ship contracted coronavirus
efforts to stop it spreading failed and
around the world this virus is testing
country's abilities to contain it in
South Korea 2.5 million people have been
urged to stay at home whose authorities
try to control a surge in cases with
more than 200 confirmed infections
health emergencies been declared so even
as some are leaving a former coronavirus
hotspot the virus is tightening its grip
elsewhere